this week on westworld
how much longer you've got to be alive
and it isn't long
multiple calebs a mole in our midst and
hail getting even more unhinged the
third last episode of westworld has come
to an end and i'm still pretty clueless
as to what's going on we're gonna get
going and stick around till the end of
the video where i go into my teaser
trailer spoiler section with hints on
where the show is headed we open on a
swing set whenever i think of sci-fi and
swing sets i always think of terminator
2. this is actually a flashback to
hale's takeover of the world via the
parasites frankie isn't that much older
in this scene than when she escaped host
carver in episode 3 suggesting that
hale's takeover was extremely quick this
is at odds with what she said in episode
4 that it took a generation for her to
gain complete control of the world so
maybe at this point she's only started
taking over california where this seems
to be set frankie and ewade have tracked
down a young jay who has started to
remember thoughts of his brother he'll
be picked up as an outlier before being
rescued this is the first place we've
seen other than new york in the 1920s
park that is equipped with these audio
transmitters at the safe house frankie
shows jay how she uses the radio and a
special frequency to send messages to
her dad but jay thinks this is a waste
of time her dad's gone just like his
brother this becomes an important scene
because it's here jay tells frankie not
to call him her brother later in the
episode when jay calls frankie his
family she knows he's a host because the
real jay would never call her that
frankie and bernard have arrived at the
abandoned 1920s park with the body of
maeve they found buried under the sand
two episodes ago if they're gonna get
her back up and running they'll need a
few things that can only be found here
in the background here you can make out
the madison avenue type area with
skyscrapers that we never really got to
explore and to the left a hidden easter
egg of the roman expansion a callback to
the original westworld film interrupting
a flashback of his daughter caleb wakes
up to find himself imprisoned under
hale's control she has this ominous red
hourglass which seems to indicate how
much time he has before his body decays
it's only a temporary body which will
break down in a matter of days of course
he wants to know where his daughter is
but hale reminds him he's not the only
one who has lost family a nod to her
family killed in season 3. hale has kept
kayla because she believes he is somehow
connected to her outlier problem a
problem which may or may not be related
to her host choosing to stay mortal
instead of transcend a process we saw
last episode hale also wants to know how
caleb disobeyed her order to kill maeve
those decades ago it was caleb after all
who told hale he has something she
doesn't we still don't know what this is
so hale thinks all these things are
connected hence why she keeps caleb
around hoping to get answers perhaps if
hale can capture frankie it will make
caleb talk and it's here we get our
first clue that within the rebels
there's a mole hale tells him that a
quote visitor is on their way we see
that caleb's build is number
278 the same number she told him in the
simulation from episode 4. caleb will
later find out his fellow prisoners are
earlier versions of him an apprehensive
frankie questions bernard about his
involvement with westworld and delos
she's still not sure what his grand plan
is they make their way underground in
search of a new control unit the one in
maeve's head would have been corrupted
after spending decades buried in the
sand ironically the control unit they
end up taking is that of temperance
hectors hector was maeve's love interest
in westworld and beyond it's also kind
of ironic that they awaken her in the
butterfly club the 1920s equivalent of
the mariposa where maeve spent most of
her life bernard says something really
interesting here that the original
founders of westworld started first with
a simulation and that hale has done the
same thing is this in any way connected
to what's happening with christina and
the quote-unquote game she's been
writing for the original parks were used
to collect data from their patrons
westworld used hats to do this but it
seems the 1920s world had improved tech
which utilized mirrors tech that played
off the most basic human impulse vanity
the processor found in the back of this
mirror will allow the data transfer from
maeve's old control unit into the new
one much more quickly back in new york
caleb is instructed by well caleb to
inspect the hourglass where he'll find a
device which pricks him and knocks him
out what he embarks on is a quest to
escape and get a message to his daughter
however this whole thing is a setup by
hail hale's been unsuccessful getting
anything out of him hell she's tried 278
times and failed so maybe by giving him
the illusion of hope she can keep tabs
on him and learn something that will
solve her problems when caleb is knocked
out he experiences memories of his
daughter and also those of his wife at
the hospital it's heavily implied he met
his wife here who is a nurse after the
incident at the lighthouse he awakens
with a drone host starting the
incineration process and escapes via a
conveniently placed grate with an etched
arrow pointing downward something that
was either planted there by hail or a
previous version of himself throughout
his escape he'll see several other of
his clones who didn't make it and i kept
thinking to myself how did hale not know
that there were all these dead bodies
everywhere but it doesn't really matter
considering this was all her plan anyway
bernard patches up maeve with that same
type of device that caleb used to treat
her gunshot wound in episode 3. we
learned that frankie's mom got sick and
it was frankie who took care of her in
her final days frankie is distrustful of
maeve considering she was the last
person she saw with her father the day
he left there's also a little talk about
how she believes hosts can't have
emotions and that their choices aren't
their own i wonder if this will change
over the course of the next two episodes
jay and stubbs arrive back with the
rescued outlier where jay tells the
group there's a mole this is how they
were discovered while in new york we'll
later find out this mole is j but jay's
human body was swapped with a host only
after they were discovered so is there
another mole or did the rebels just get
unlucky frankie initially shoots bernard
believing him to be the mold after she
discovered he was secretly copying her
he's trying to copy all of us all
bernard says in response to this is that
it's complicated and they need to trust
him jay wants to destroy me but frankie
refuses believing her to be the only
thing that has info about her father a
series of bloody handprints lead caleb
along this path of his previous clones
he'll end up finding a small room of his
exact same clothing even copies of his
wedding ring after a drone host almost
gets the better of him he coughs up
blood indicating that his time is short
because bernard has been through this
simulation thousands of times he knows
that the mole is one of frankie's
friends in fact the mole turned out to
be completely different people in
different simulations so he can't
pinpoint exactly who it is perhaps
bernard had frankie analyzed to verify
that she herself wasn't the mole
regardless he says that there wasn't a
single version of the simulation where
all of them make it out alive frankie
will either have to kill one of them or
they will kill her her paranoia has her
lock up her girlfriend odina the fallout
of which we'll likely see in the
episodes to come in one of the more
outrageous moments of the show caleb
uses a copy of himself to break his fall
from the ventilation shaft talk about
teamwork he has another flashback this
one of teaching an injured frankie that
the person who can't be beat is the
person that doesn't give up echoing his
own journey these past 23 years this is
a man who hasn't given up frankie
uncovers that it's jay who is the mole
he was switched while in new york he
tells her he doesn't want to kill her
and that may be because she's useful to
hail and can be used as a bargaining
chip against caleb speaking of caleb he
sends a message out to his daughter who
he refers to as cookie maybe that's why
she calls herself c he apologizes for
his failure as a father and not being
there for her he may have lost to hale
but she still has a chance it's a
message that she'll hear only a brief
portion of before jay shoots the radio
but it's maeve who saves frankie by
stabbing jay in the head for maeve it's
time for her and frankie to finish what
caleb started hale is frustrated caleb
spent all this time escaping only to
send what she calls a worthless message
caleb tells her it wasn't the humans who
infected the hosts rather that the host
would rather die than live in her world
this pisses her off and she kills him
we'll later see her picking at her scar
something we saw her do last episode
hale has all the caleb's incinerated it
kind of echoes what happened to james
delos senior in season 2 when it looked
like his quest for fidelity would not be
possible fidelity is the name of this
episode and refers to the process of
creating a human host hybrid to see if
they're true to the human they're
supposed to represent but hale isn't
giving up we see that the 279th
version of caleb is already being made
the marking of the great is covered up
perhaps hinting that hale has to try a
new approach we see her visiting this
new caleb in a rather interesting
position it's the same one he was in
while holding his gunshot wound in the
simulation suggesting this is hale going
through the same thing she did with the
previous versions he'll wake up run away
and be brought back in it seems the only
way she'll get anything out of caleb is
if she finally catches frankie but to
find out what happens we'll need to wait
for next episode up next is the teaser
trailer section where i go over some of
the shots we haven't seen yet to see if
there's anything we can learn i talked
about this one last week but this looks
like stubbs returning to new york or at
least some other populous city we'll
later see him at this abandoned
drugstore where clementine is there's
also this shot of what might be caleb
fighting clementine remember that
clementine was tasked with dealing with
caleb honestly if hale really wanted to
find frankie the best course of action
would be to let him go and track him
here's dolores or christina in some
water not exactly sure what's going on
here william shoots someone maybe it's
lawrence maybe not bernard is shot and
this looks far more serious than how he
was shot in this episode remember he
said there's no version of the story
where he survives a reflection of what
may be dolores christina with the
abernathy ranch william arrives at the
hoover dam where we see a big tear
similar to the one which led to the
sublime in season two william purchased
all the data in those servers there but
hasn't been able to get at them because
the files are encrypted i've theorized
that the real william may have switched
places with host william after host
william got infected so it may be the
real william who's chasing down hale at
the dam in this shot here's maeve
finally confronting charlotte looks like
she made it to new york and is that the
same knife that was used to kill jay i
also found this weird looking bell that
charlotte holds i wonder what that's for
this shot is super perplexing where we
can make out an early model of a host
exoskeleton we've seen dolores with this
in the past the man in black emerges
from the body-filled streets of what
might be california is this a flashback
to when the flies started taking over or
is this something else entirely maybe
he's hunting down the rebels so that's
pretty much it for this week i can't
believe we only have two more episodes
and the westworld saga comes to an end i
hope you'll consider liking and
subscribing as i'll be covering those as
well thanks for watching everyone and
for more bad takes you can follow me on
twitter and instagram at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember if there's
anyone who doesn't know what dallas is
well as we've always said dallas is the
vacation of the future today